hey guys this is final fantasy 12 the
zodiac age the remake of the original
I'm Callie I'm here with Miguel
concepción hello Miguel tell us what
we're looking at right now well we are
exploring a town called faun coast it's
one of the many towns in filefast a12
and we are looking at it in its
remastered glory all right so I didn't
play the original tell me a little bit
of background about final fantasy 12
well final fantasy 12 is part of this
aside from being a main line final
fantasy it is part of a game project
that is known as the Ivelisse Alliance
which is which comprises of Final
Fantasy Tactics Final Fantasy Tactics at
vans and it's within this world called
evil E's a world that was also the basis
for vagrant story so we loaded up a safe
to play today so where are we in the
story with the context we need here well
without spoiling it for the people who
are going to be playing final fantasy 12
for the first time the basic story
involves two warring kingdoms and the
smaller I guess the smaller regions that
are caught in the middle of it and these
characters are just swept up in in the
chaos and the the bedlam of the warring
of the warring nations the to care the
the six playable character six playable
main characters have drawn interesting
comparisons to some some of the cast of
some of the characters from Star Wars
um in what way well people draw
comparisons we got let's see let's look
at the party right here we got vaad who
comes off as sort of like the the the
Luke Skywalker very sort of like young
sort of just like hungry for adventure
bothy a he saw
comes off as the the I guess the Han
Solo type character his companion is
this bunny lady named Fran already sold
I like yes and so people call her sexy
Chewbacca sometimes that's the nickname
she has inherited and my apologies to
the fans if I butcher some of these
names but Bosch is sort of the obi-wan
character while ash is this exiled not
so much exiled she's this missing
princess of the of the of the region
that is caught in the crossfire of the
two larger nations and penelo by default
and being a Vaughan's old friend she
served the c-3po mm-hmm so alright
excellent so who's your favorite you
know what uh I seem to be attached to
Ashe okay um so I guess my first
question now that we're jumping in and
kind of running around here is as
somebody who played the original how
long ago did it come out again at 2006
or 2007
alright so about ten years ago why is
Final Fantasy if you have played the
original what's worth returning to well
this is funny you mention that because I
for the longest time I put final fantasy
12 as what is probably like one of the
greatest games that I could never
imagine fighting time to play again
mm-hmm
because of just how complete my initial
playthrough was but zodiac Age gives me
every possible reason to jump back in it
I mean aside from the fact that it's you
know it's remastered plus it has this
you can listen to the original music
plus orchestrated music which we will
check out later it also features uh
it has all the features from the
international
International zodiac job system edition
which did not come out in the States
oh okay so for those of us who really
like an authentic like a Japanese JRPG
without anything stripped away that's
something that didn't even come to the
state so I guess right
it was the zodiac international job
system edition came out shortly after
final fantasy 12 came out in the States
I believe and it just uh served it gets
its name from its improved progression
system gotcha
which I will show in a sec so what is
your favorite thing about you probably
have a lot of things but what is now
that we're looking at combat what do you
like about combat in final fantasy 12
you know I will say it's actually my
favorite it might very well be my
favorite JRPG combat system of all time
okay so let's let's talk about that
because I don't know more about that
because I love a good JRPG combat system
what what should appeal to me well we're
not we're not using picture and picture
so you can actually show that I'm barely
doing anything with my controller but as
we didn't see yeah all my characters are
behaving on their own without me putting
and making any inputs that's not to say
the computer or the AI it's AI
controlled no you actually a full
ownership of the actions and full
control of the actions of your of your
team you are just able to customize
their commands with what they call the
gambit system a whole series of if-then
actions so I your ties so for me I have
a little bit of a background in
programming and so I understand I
understand very little but I do
understand a good if/then statement so
that appeals to me right away so explain
that a little bit more so as you can see
with most of these attacking the enemy
is served low in the priority because
there are all these other situations
that you need to prepare for whether
like here we're in in France it is
anticipating that there might be a
character who's going to get ko'd okay
so you're like if Ally status equals KO
then
she uses Phoenix down that happens
before she does anything else below that
okay so that is your first priority from
whatever for the scripts that you've
written here everybody it seems like
everybody has that yeah
I'm chef yeah and actually a tag should
be pretty low red is so blue is
defensive stuff and healing it looks
like it and then red is offensive right
the interesting thing about about this
uh battle system is that you have to
earn your way towards getting the
different the additional lines on the
gambit system plus the actual gambits
you actually have to earn through
purchasing in towns okay so there's a
lot of work that goes into the scripting
so so you like it because like this is a
lot of strategy there's a lot of
forethought forethought that goes into
this but I guess the big thing big thing
for me is like am I just going to end up
watching my party take down enemies like
do what do you do in battle then you
might find yourself like going through
like in and out an hour of exploring an
area without ever pressing a button
you're just but there it doesn't deprive
you of the sense of gratification of
well you wrote those scripts yes you
wrote you wrote those scripts it's like
I think ideally I mean to set up like a
perfect gambit for yourself what you're
essentially doing is showcasing your
most conservative rational side as as
someone who takes on JRPG battles it's
like if you if you think about all those
times that like the enemy has just just
a sliver of health left but they've
managed to poison you do you spend that
last turn vanquishing the enemy or do
you actually just use an antidote
when I say conservative that means that
you'll that using this system you'll
most likely prioritize using the end of
those verses just taking a chance on
killing the enemy
although it sort of takes out sort of
like the impulsiveness that can lead to
mistakes in JRPG battles gotcha
so you do that pre-planning and then you
don't have to you don't run the risk of
messing up right um
how long did it take you to get to this
point because we like obviously loaded
up a save how long did it take you to
get these scripts to where you want it
like did you because right now you are
not pressing like any buttons for these
battles did you start the game having to
do a lot more inputs and having to bat a
little more traditional oh absolutely
the game if you actually noticed here
actually one of my characters actually
got knocked out um but thanks to the
gambit system one of the characters
already saved them but anyway um the
game does a really good job in
introducing you to the whole system so
it's a bit of a slow burn but it's it
doesn't take that long relatively
speaking in the scheme of game that can
easily take over a hundred hours you
know the two hours you spend leading up
to actually learning a gambit system
isn't too bad right um you actually do
spend maybe like the first half hour
actually it almost feels like a
traditional JRPG but within an hour or
two you start using your gambits mm-hmm
so for a while I guess like because I'm
imagining because I haven't played this
again I'm imagining like myself watching
this battle because right now my biggest
concern is oh what I get for just
watching battles go down and now I'm
thinking oh if I'm like learning from my
scripts and if something wasn't working
now I'm watching this battle and kind of
taking mental notes right is that sort
of what your process is like oh
absolutely it's like I'm just guessing
based on watching you play and not
having to do anything which is actually
like very gratifying yeah and you know
again you're the one who constructs
these scripts right um well it's like if
you program something and then you got
your computer to do your work for you
then it's like that's still exciting
because you're the one who made that
work exactly
so okay this is an interesting situation
because it looks like the I might be out
of my league
I was about to say is there are there
times where like an enemy is stronger
than normal and you do want to do manual
inputs you can just kind of override it
anytime
yes you can yeah you can like attack it
anytime you anytime I want like right
here okay so you guys the action
gambits are on but you can go in and
kind of make alterations right as you
see fit change my target not you know
that well that's a kowai but you do make
you do bring up you know it's like
having to watch now one of the features
from the International zodiac job
edition that came out is the option to
actually speed up the gameplay I was
about to ask about this so the gambit
system is from the original and then
this option to speed up is something
that we didn't see in the States correct
okay so you can like totally speed up a
battle and then you won't have to worry
too much if you have your game before
you want them right yeah you just have
to really be on point with your gambits
right yeah I wouldn't want to risk
speeding it up and then dying suddenly
because I didn't write a good enough
right but this is like super helpful if
at any point the plot like compels you
to go back in easier areas mm-hmm you
could still get the quote-unquote
currency to level up well you know your
while still relying on your gambits but
you don't feel like you're wasting your
time and that's another thing because
even like the the most insignificant
enemies enemies that were only a
challenge in the first two hours of the
game they still um provide like like you
know useful Zoar loot and experience
which is probably a good transition into
the the License Board which is the the
main area of the progression um if you
look at every enemy I kill there's this
unit that they draw that you earn called
LP which is licensed point okay um those
licenses it's it's how you get to decide
the
progression of your characters mm-hmm
what's here and that's something that
was enhanced in the what is it zodiac
job zodiac International jobs job system
I love that title because I'll never
remember it so we're looking at the
License Board which if if you have
pretty photographic memory of the
original US version this is quite a
drastic change what I had in the
original version it was just this giant
board and there were there wasn't even
like really any jobs or at least not in
the the same level specificity that you
see here this wheel of the 12 zodiacs
that wasn't there in the US version okay
and so this would you say this is an
improvement over the original US version
then like this give you better control
over what what you're doing in terms of
control absolutely what's the what's the
main difference besides appearance and
in UI I believe being able to make each
character specialize in certain jobs now
the one the jobs being like black mage
bushi right yeah now the really
interesting thing about that that is new
to file fancy 12 as new to zodiac age
that has not appeared in international
zodiac job system oh is the fact that
each character can have two jobs
woo the MA very modern
yeah so given that you have six
characters 12 signs when I do my
official review playthrough when I do my
review playthrough I want to spread them
out evenly you want to be able to cuz
with six characters who can have two
jobs each you'll be able to get all the
jobs possible you kind of see how all of
them work okay um but for just as a
disclaimer we're actually working off
save files that Square Enix provided for
us so I didn't have to like play all the
way to this point right I'm curious as
to why the the percent Square Enix who
created save file have three characters
as nice
to read battle mages um I don't know why
but I think because I'm a little OCD I
would have loved to have had it pretty
spread out evenly yeah but going to back
to this board yeah the LP which is on
the upper left-hand corner that is that
matches the the points that you see here
in each tile
you could spend however much you have oh
and so the grayed out ones are ones you
haven't unlocked yet right and then when
you can you go back to the original
screen actually so then you can see what
you've invested in is it like an
abstraction of it
yes well yeah uh and so has this says to
me this is super complicated looking but
has it enhanced like your memory of
playing final fantasy 12 for the first
time like is it something that helps or
is it just kind of like a cool new
addition to keep it fresh it's it's a
different take on the license board I
you know I had spent so much time with
the original game that you know
progression what didn't seem like it
wasn't a hidden hindrance I mean I felt
like my progression in the story was in
sync with my progression on the board I
never felt like I was I had to Ness neat
and do some extra grinding right um it's
it's different in the sense that as I
said it's you're now your characters are
not that much more sort of specialized
the board is smaller now but you spread
it across two jobs okay and there's a
lot there's a lot of those tiles to
spend on and again we are letting the
gambit system take care of the combat
let's what's interesting is that you can
actually speed up the multiplier to four
time oh my gosh okay I want to see this
in action oh yes
so bad
and so does this help with grinding like
deep or did you cuz you just said you
didn't really feel the need to grind too
much belly if you could just set the
game at system going
put it on four times speed you could
probably grind forever and like it
wouldn't feel like that much time yeah
it wouldn't feel that much time I don't
think it would be cheating I mean Square
Enix is offering this option and you
know if it turns out it it reduces my
total playtime to half great um I mean
especially if like if you're the kind of
person who likes JRPGs and likes JRPGs
systems but are a little put off by the
time investment or maybe like you said
at the beginning like this is a game
that you you thought you might never
return to because of the time investment
if you can kind of have that that helps
get over that very comment like JRPG
time hurdle but I think um something
that always prohibited me from this is
why I've never played this game is like
I just didn't have enough time to spread
between all the games I wanted to play
in a JRPG is such a huge time sink like
a JRPG of this magnitude so yeah and you
know it does go into an interesting
point about leveling and grinding in
this game there is a leveling exploit
from the original game where there's
there was a particular enemy that you
could encounter about halfway through
the game maybe a little make two-thirds
into the game who spawns these lesser
enemies so technically so theoretically
you could have created a gambit whereby
you would have up ignore the big enemy
and just focus on the lesser enemies
that it kept spawning so you were able
to like create an auto level farming
system right by creating a creating a
gambit where you're like just focusing
on the lesser enemy in that encounter so
eventually when I was playing the game I
said I met that enemy I left my
playstation 2 alone I came back to it
after 36 hours and my three active
members
or level 99 oh my god so I haven't had a
chance to test whether or not that
exploit is still present in this game
but it would be interesting if it still
was very very interesting okay any last
thoughts on the battle system before we
wrap up uh nope um I think we described
it pretty pretty well hey thoroughly
yeah all right I am definitely intrigued
that's just being such a unique system I
definitely want to jump into this game
now that it's coming out with all these
updates in a time where I'm not trying
to get into college so I can actually
have time to play it so I'm pretty much
sold I think just checking it out has
really piqued my interest so I'm excited
the one thing we should end with is a
little bit sampling of the new
orchestrated music let's do it
and we should note that the music does
not speed up I was about to say it
sounds normal
alright well that is the first of a
couple videos about final final fantasy
12 the zodiac age so be sure to
subscribe to gang spot on YouTube so you
can catch more of those as they come out
scheme isn't coming up for a while so
just keep on the lookout you don't want
to miss thing thanks for watching thank
you